Hey y'all, it's Kelly Clarkson with Wayfair. Ever order furniture online and wonder, what if? Like, what if it doesn't hold up? That sofa was four days old. You should have ordered from Wayfair. With Wayfair, there's no what if. Just style you love and quality you can trust. Visit Wayfair.ca.
大家好，我是凯莉·克拉克森，与Wayfair合作。你是否曾在网上订购家具时想过：如果……会怎样？比如，如果它不结实怎么办？那张沙发才用了四天。你本该在Wayfair订购的。在Wayfair，没有什么“如果”，只有你喜爱的设计和你可以信赖的品质。访问Wayfair.ca。
Wayfair, every style, every home. Feeling loved is something all of us want. It's essential to our health and happiness. But we don't always get to experience it, even in our closest relationships. You probably have people in your life who care about you, deeply, your friends, your family, a spouse or a partner, and yet you sometimes still feel unseen or disconnected from them. Why is that? What's the difference between being loved and feeling loved? How does psychologists define love in the first place? Why is feeling loved so essential? And why can
Wayfair，各种风格，温馨小家。渴望被爱是所有人共同的心愿。它是我们健康和幸福的基石。但我们并不总能体验到它，即便在我们最亲密的关系中也是如此。你的生活中可能有人深爱着你，比如你的朋友、家人、配偶或伴侣，然而你有时仍会觉得他们看不到你，或者与他们疏离。这是为什么？被爱和感觉被爱之间有什么区别？心理学家最初是如何定义爱的？为什么感觉被爱如此重要？以及为什么
it sometimes be so hard to achieve even when love is there? What gets in the way? And what mindsets or habits can help people feel more loved in their everyday lives. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Harry Reese, Dean's Professor in the Department of Psychology at the University of Rochester. His research focuses on intimacy and understanding in close relationships, and especially on how being responsive to our partners shapes our relationships. Dr. Reese is an APA fellow and has published more than 250 papers in academic journals.
有时即使爱就在那里，也很难实现？是什么阻碍了我们？什么样的心态或习惯能帮助人们在日常生活中感受到更多的爱。欢迎收听《心理学说话》，这是美国心理学协会的旗舰播客，探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我今天的嘉宾是罗彻斯特大学心理学系教授、院长讲席教授哈里·里斯博士。他的研究重点是亲密关系和亲密关系中的理解，尤其是对伴侣的响应如何塑造我们的关系。里斯博士是美国心理学协会会士，在学术期刊上发表了250多篇论文。
He has received distinguished career contribution awards from the Society for Personality and Social Psychology and the International Association for Relationship Research, and his work has been featured in media outlets including NPR, the New York Times, and Scientific American. His new book, written with happiness researcher Dr. Sonia Leibomerski, is called How to Feel Love, the five mindsets that get you more of what matters most. Dr. Reese, thank you for joining me today. It's a pleasure to be here today, Kim. The title of your book is How to Feel Loved, so let's start there.
他曾获得人格与社会心理学协会以及国际关系研究协会的杰出职业贡献奖，他的研究成果曾在NPR、《纽约时报》和《科学美国人》等媒体上亮相。他的新书与幸福感研究人员索尼亚·柳博米尔斯基博士合著，书名为《如何感受爱：让你收获更多最重要的东西的五种心态》。里斯博士，谢谢你今天能来。很高兴今天能来到这里，金。你的书名为《如何感受爱》，那我们就从这里开始吧。
How do you define love in your work, and what's the difference between being loved and feeling loved? Well, we take a very broad approach to the word love. You know, love is one of the most ambiguous words in the English language when you think about it. It can apply to a romantic relationship. It can apply to how parents feel about their children, and it can apply to how you feel about chocolate ice cream. So we tried to find a definition that would fit with most kinds of human relationships that people have.
你在工作中如何定义爱，被爱和感觉被爱有什么区别？嗯，我们对“爱”这个词采取了非常广义的វិធី。你知道，仔细想想，爱是英语中最含糊不清的词之一。它适用于恋爱关系。它适用于父母对孩子的感情，也适用于你对巧克力冰淇淋的感情。所以我们试图找到一个能够适应人们所经历的大多数人类关系的定义。
And so we defined love in terms of feelings of caring and connection and warmth, the kind of feeling that one gets when one feels understood, cared for, appreciated, and seen. So our definition very explicitly goes beyond romance, although romance is certainly covered in that as well. You asked about the difference between being loved and feeling loved, and that's a very important distinction to us and to most people. Being loved is what other people express and regard with respect to you. Feeling loved is how you feel about what they're doing. You know, somebody can love you, somebody can express love to you by giving you presents, by telling you how much they care, by sending you Valentine's Day cards. Feeling loved is when you take it in inside, when you feel, yes, that person
因此，我们用关心、连接和温暖的感觉来定义爱，也就是当一个人感到被理解、被关心、被感激和被看见时所获得的感受。所以我们的定义非常明确地超越了浪漫，尽管浪漫当然也包含在其中。你问到被爱和感觉被爱之间的区别，这对我们以及大多数人来说都是一个非常重要的区别。被爱是其他人对你表达和看待的方式。感觉被爱则是你对他们所作所为的感受。你知道，有人可以爱你，有人可以通过送你礼物、告诉你他们有多在乎你、给你发情人节卡片来向你表达爱。感觉被爱是指你把它内化于心，当你觉得，是的，那个人
really gets me, that person really cares about me, that person is really concerned about my well-being. And that's a very, very crucial distinction because many people are loved and yet they don't feel loved. What does the research tell us about why feeling loved is so important? Well, feeling loved is so important because it connects to just a variety of things that are so important for people's lives. Take, for example, the loneliness epidemic. People who are lonely don't feel loved. On the other hand, people who are not lonely, most definitely do feel loved. So one way to think about it is at the root cause of a general sense of ill-being and disconnection. And that ill-feeling in return is responsible for so many important things in life.
真的懂我，那个人真的很在乎我，那个人真的很关心我的福祉。这是一个非常非常关键的区别，因为许多人被爱着，却没有感受到爱。研究告诉我们为什么感觉被爱如此重要？嗯，感觉被爱之所以如此重要，是因为它与对人们生活至关重要的各种事情息息相关。以孤独流行病为例。感到孤独的人感觉不到爱。另一方面，不感到孤独的人，绝对能感受到爱。所以，思考这个问题的一种方法是将其视为整体幸福感缺失和疏离感的根源。而这种糟糕的感受反过来又对生活中的许多重要事情负有责任。
For example, when people don't feel loved, they don't work as effectively. Young people in school don't do as well. and much more interestingly, I think, is the idea that it's not only our mental and emotional health that suffers, but it's also our physical health, it's our proneness to disease. And interestingly enough, people who don't feel loved tend to die sooner. Are there misconceptions people have about love that make it harder for some of us to actually feel loved? Well, the great irony in all this, I think, is the idea that people often will realize that they don't feel as loved as they want. And what they will do is often counterproductive. That is, it is often the kind of thing that actually makes it harder to feel loved rather than helping them feel loved. For example, one of the things that people will do is they try to make themselves as attractive as possible, as successful as people.
例如，当人们感觉不到爱时，他们的工作效率就会降低。学校里的年轻人表现也会变差。更有趣的是，我认为，不仅仅是我们的心理和情感健康受到影响，我们的身体健康、对疾病的易感性也会受到影响。有趣的是，感觉不到爱的人往往会更早离世。人们对爱是否存在误解，使得我们中的一些人更难真正感受到爱？嗯，这一切中最大的讽刺，我认为，是人们经常会意识到他们没有感受到他们想要的那么多爱。而他们通常会采取适得其反的行动。也就是说，这些做法往往实际上使他们更难感受到爱，而不是帮助他们感受到爱。例如，人们会做的一件事是，他们试图让自己尽可能迷人、尽可能成功。
possible, as strong as possible, as accomplished as possible. And if you doubt that people will try this, just take a look at profiles that people post on online dating. Those profiles are always trumpeting one's virtues. They never mention one's shortcomings. They never mention the things that make one a unique human being. And the reason that I say that these strategies are counterproductive is that they may well help you feel admired. It may well make other people think, wow, that person is really impressive. But that's not what feeling loved is about.
尽可能坚强、尽可能有成就。如果你怀疑人们会这样做，只需看看人们在在线约会上发布的个人资料。这些个人资料总是大肆宣扬自己的优点。他们从不提及自己的缺点。他们从不提及让自己成为一个独特的人的事物。我之所以说这些策略适得其反，是因为它们很可能会让你感到被钦佩。它很可能会让其他人觉得，哇，这个人真的很令人印象深刻。但这不是感觉被爱。
Feeling loved is about being recognized and appreciated for the total person that one is. And if you only present a curated image of your strength and accomplishments, you never allow the other person to see the real you, and you never allow yourself to feel what they might express about the real you. So one of the central theses of our book is the idea that in order to feel loved, one has to be able to express the full total self that one has, warts and shortcomings, as well as strengths and accomplishments.
感觉被爱是关于作为一个完整的人而被认可和赞赏。如果你只展示一个经过精心策划的坚强和成就的形象，你就永远不会让另一个人看到真实的你，你也永远不会让自己感受到他们对真实的你所表达的感受。因此，我们书中的核心论点之一是，为了感受到爱，一个人必须能够表达自己完整、全面的自我，包括缺点和短处，以及优点和成就。
Do you run the risk of having everything backfire when you say to somebody, I don't feel like you love me enough. I mean, what approach do you take in order to get somebody to give you that, that love and let you feel that you really are appreciated? I think that question is guaranteed to produce a backlash. Because, you know, if somebody says that to me, I'm going to get defensive. I'm going to, well, what do you mean? I'm trying to tell you how much I love you, damn it.
当你对某人说“我觉得你不够爱我”时，会不会冒着一切适得其反的风险？我的意思是，为了让某人给你这种爱并让你觉得你真的被感激了，你采取什么方法？我认为这个问题注定会产生强烈反弹。因为，你知道，如果有人对我这么说，我会进行防御。我会，嗯，你什么意思？该死，我正试图告诉你我有多爱你。
You know, our sense of the way you go about things, if you don't feel as loved as you would like to feel, is to initiate a series of conversations with another person that allow love to be expressed freely back and forth. So one of the things that you can do, and this may sound ironic, because it starts off with helping the other person feel loved. So we offer a series of mindsets in our book, and the one that I think is the best place to start is one that we we call listen to learn. The listen to learn mindset says when you're talking to another person, really listen to them as if they were going to be a quiz tomorrow. So often when we're so-called listening to another person, we're preparing our response to the next, you know,
你知道，我们对你如何处理事情的看法是，如果你没有感受到你希望感受到的爱，就是与另一个人展开一系列对话，让爱能够自由地来回表达。所以你可以做的一件事听起来可能很讽刺，因为它是从帮助另一个人感到被爱开始的。因此，我们在书中提供了一系列心态，我认为最好的起点是我们将之称为“倾听以学习”的心态。“倾听以学习”的心态表明，当你与另一个人交谈时，要真正倾听他们，就像明天会有关于他们的测验一样。通常，当我们所谓的在倾听另一个人时，我们正在准备对下一个的回应，你知道，
what are we going to say next? Where are we going to go? How can I change the topic? Oh, how do I get out of this conversation to talk to this other person? Or how do I impress you with, you know, how I know so much about the thing you're talking about. All of those things interfere with creating a real meaningful kind of connection. And if you instead approach the other person with a real genuine curiosity, with a real sense of, I'd really like to know more about that because that's really interesting to me. I'd like to know what makes you tick. I'd like to know why you feel that way. When you went to that movie last night, what was it about that movie that you really liked? And something really interesting happens then. It's almost like a light bulb goes off in the other
我们接下来要说什么？我们要去哪里？我怎么能转移话题？哦，我怎么才能脱身这场对话去和另一个人谈话？或者我怎么能用我对自己正在谈论的事情了解多少来给你留下深刻印象。所有这些事情都会妨碍建立真正有意义的连接。如果你反而以真正的、真诚的好奇心去接近另一个人，带着一种“我真的很想了解更多，因为这对我真的很有趣”的真正感觉。我想知道是什么让你这样。我想知道你为什么会有这种感觉。当你昨晚去看那部电影时，那部电影有什么让你真正喜欢的？然后会发生一些非常有趣的事情。这几乎就像另一个人的脑海里亮起了一个灯泡。
person's head. They say, huh, this person's really listening to me. And that often can trigger the kind of conversation that we think eventually leads to feeling loved. Okay, so that's one of the mindsets, the listen to learn mindset, but there are five in the book. So can you talk about the others? What are they? Well, I actually slipped a second one in there because the listen to learn mindset goes closely with the second mindset that is called radical curiosity. The idea of being and expressing curiosity about the other person. You know, people are so interesting. You know, we psychologists are perennially interested in what makes people tick, what drives their behavior. So when you show enthusiasm, when you show energy, when you show that you're really and genuinely interested in the
他们说，嗯，这个人真的在听我说话。这通常可以触发我们认为最终会导致感受到爱的对话。好吧，这就是其中一种心态，倾听以学习的心态，但书中还有五种。你能谈谈其他的吗？它们是什么？嗯，其实我刚才顺便提了第二种，因为“倾听以学习”的心态与被称为“激进好奇心”的第二种心态密切相关。关于对另一个人保持并表达好奇心的想法。你知道，人是如此有趣。你知道，我们心理学家对是什么让人们行动、是什么推动他们的行为一直很感兴趣。所以当你表现出热情，当你表现出活力，当你表现出你对另一个人真实而真诚的兴趣时，这就是引发这个过程的原因。
other person, that's what ticks off the process. Now, close to that is a third mindset, which we call the open heart mindset, which essentially has the idea that when one shows interest in another person, it can't just be, you know, I'm taking notes for the test tomorrow. It's got to be accompanied by a sense of caring and concern, a sense of compassion for the other person, a sense that you're really interested in their well-being. You really want to express positive, benevolent feelings toward them. Some listeners may be thinking, but wait a minute, what he's talking about is going to help the other person feel loved.
与之接近的是第三种心态，我们称之为开放的心态，其实质是当一个人对另一个人表现出兴趣时，不能只是，你知道，我在为明天的考试做笔记。它必须伴随着一种关心和关切感，一种对另一个人的同情心，一种你真的对他们的福祉感兴趣的感觉。你真的想向他们表达积极的、仁慈的感情。一些听众可能会想，但是等一下，他正在谈论的事情将有助于另一个人感到被爱。
How does that make me feel more loved? And the answer lies in a process that's very well known to researchers who study social interaction. The idea that reciprocity is one of the strongest rules of social behavior that we have. So think, let's say you do the three mindsets that I was just talking about. Well, that will lift the other person up, much like on a seesaw when you go down and you help the other person rise up. And then what happens? they return the favor. And it's the returning the favor that gives you an opportunity to express the fourth mindset. And the fourth mindset is about being open and sharing and vulnerable about oneself.
这怎么能让我感觉更被爱呢？答案在于一个研究社会互动的研究人员非常熟知的过程。互惠是我们拥有的最强大的社会行为规则之一的想法。所以想想，假设你执行了我刚才谈到的三种心态。嗯，这会振奋另一个人，就像在跷跷板上你往下坐，帮助另一个人升起一样。然后会发生什么？他们回报恩惠。正是这种回报恩惠为你提供了表达第四种心态的机会。第四种心态是关于对自己的开放、分享和脆弱。
So disclosing things that are real about oneself, not just talking about superficial attitudes, not just talking about the weather, not just trumpeting one's strengths, but instead getting to a point where one can share what makes one a unique human being, what's special, what's interesting, and that, and when the other person responds positively to that, that's when you kick off the back and forth dynamic of sharing and listening and sharing and showing appreciation, and it goes back and forth. And as a result of those kind of conversations, a person is likely to feel loved. Now I'm going to play devil's advocate for a minute here. You say in the book that the key to feeling more loved is not to change yourself, but then you offer some strategies that
所以要透露关于自己的真实事情，而不仅仅是谈论表面的态度，不仅谈论天气，不仅仅大肆宣扬自己的优点，而是达到能够分享是什么让自己成为一个独特的人、什么是特别的、什么是有趣的，并且，当另一个人对此做出积极回应时，这就是你开启分享和倾听、分享和表达感激的来回动态的时候，它来回进行。作为这些对话的结果，一个人更有可能感到被爱。现在我要唱一会儿反调。你在书中说，获得更多爱的关键不是改变自己，但接着你又提供了一些
actually might ask some people to be different, you know, to listen better, to ask more questions, to be more interested in the other person. I mean, for some people, that could be a pretty fundamental change. You know, some folks, as you said, they're not good listeners. They're just waiting for the opportunity to say what it is that they want to say. So how to you? So how How do you respond to that? I mean, don't you have to change in some way? I love that question. And what I would say is we're suggesting that you don't change yourself, but that you change your behavior. It's not saying you need to be more attractive. You need to publish more articles. You need to go to the gym more often. We're not saying you need to change
实际上可能会要求某些人变得不同的策略，你知道，更好地倾听，提出更多问题，对另一个人更感兴趣。我的意思是，对某些人来说，这可能是一个相当根本的改变。你知道，正如你所说，有些人不是好的倾听者。他们只是在等待机会说出他们想说的话。那么你呢？所以你对此有何回应？我的意思是，你难道不需要在某些方面做出改变吗？我喜欢这个问题。我要说的是，我们建议你不要改变自己，而是改变你的行为。这并不是说你需要变得更有吸引力。你需要发表更多文章。你需要更频繁地去健身房。我们并不是说你需要改变
who you are. We're saying you need to change the way you interact with other people. You know, for some people, some of these behaviors may seem a little foreign. So one way to think about it is as an experiment. Try doing something different when you're talking to someone tonight and they tell you about something that happened to them. Say, tell me more. I'd really like to know more about what that meal felt like. Which of the foods did you really like the best? And experiment with that. That doesn't require changing your personality. It doesn't require changing. who you fundamentally are as a person. It simply means adopting a different orientation, a different approach when you're talking to somebody. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk more with Dr. Reese about how to get these conversations started. This spring, denim gets a softer, lighter update. Introducing Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg, a new fit that moves with you. It's everything you want denim to feel like for summer. Easy, breathable, and effortlessly cool. With a fit that
你是谁。我们说的是你需要改变你与他人互动的方式。你知道，对某些人来说，其中一些行为可能看起来有点陌生。所以思考这个问题的一种方法是将其视为一个实验。今晚和某人交谈时尝试做一些不同的事情，当他们告诉你发生在他们身上的事情时。说，告诉我更多。我真的很想更多地了解那一顿饭的感觉。你最喜欢哪种食物？并对此进行试验。这不需要改变你的个性。它不需要改变。你作为一个人的根本本质。它仅仅意味着当你与某人交谈时采用不同的方向，不同的方法。我们将做一个简短的休息。当我们回来时，我将与里斯博士更多地讨论如何开始这些对话。今年春天，牛仔裤将进行更柔软、更轻盈的更新。隆重推出 Old Navy 的垂坠牛仔阔腿裤，这是一种随你而动的全新版型。这是你对夏天牛仔裤的所有期望。轻松、透气、毫不费力地酷。具有版型
creates natural movement and a wide leg that feels modern, not overwhelming. Plus, that signature, wait, for this price? Moment. Old Navy's drapey denim wide leg. This episode is brought to you by L'Oreal Group. Beauty is a powerful force that moves us. That's why L'Oreal Group has built a business that is inclusive at its heart with 100% of its brands, championing diversity.
创造自然的运动感，阔腿感觉现代而不压抑。此外，还有标志性的“等等，这个价格？”的时刻。Old Navy 的垂坠牛仔阔腿裤。本集由欧莱雅集团为您呈现。美是一种强大的力量，能感动我们。这就是为什么欧莱雅集团建立了一个以包容为核心的业务，其 100% 的品牌都倡导多元化。
With 25,000 professional opportunities for people under 30 worldwide and 54% of leading positions held by women. Diversity is a strength that helps Loreal Group create the best beauty products for all people. Visit lorail.com to learn more. So if you've identified a relationship in your life where you think you'd like to feel more loved, how do you start? What do you do first? In principle, you can start with any of the mindsets.
在全球范围内为 30 岁以下的人群提供 25,000 个职业机会，其中 54% 的领导岗位由女性担任。多元化是一种力量，可帮助欧莱雅集团为所有人创造最好的美容产品。访问 lorail.com 了解更多信息。因此，如果你在生活中找到了一个你认为希望感受到更多爱的关系，你该如何开始？你首先做什么？原则上，你可以从任何心态开始。
The one that I like to start with when I'm trying to create these kinds of feelings is the listen to learn one. It's the one I think that's most controllable. You can simply walk into the next conversation and start to ask the person questions about what they're saying. Don't try to get in, you know, your strengths and your accomplishments. Simply talk more about what the other person's interested in. Now, interestingly enough, this is not entirely a new suggestion. In 1938, Dale Carnegie wrote the second bestselling book of all time, How to Win Friends and Influence People. And one of his major tips is talk about what the other person is interested in and do it sincerely.
当我试图创造这些感觉时，我喜欢从“倾听以学习”开始。我认为这是最可控的。你可以直接进入下一个对话，并开始向这个人询问他们所说的话。不要试图融入，你知道，你的优势和成就。只需更多地谈论另一个人感兴趣的事情。现在，有趣的是，这并非完全是一个全新的建议。1938年，戴尔·卡耐基写下了有史以来第二畅销的书《人性的弱点》。他的主要技巧之一就是谈论别人感兴趣的话题，并且要真诚地这样做。
And that's exactly what we're suggesting, that when you listen to learn and when you show radical curiosity and an open-hearted mindset, you're paying attention to what the other person says. And you're doing it in a way that conveys a very simple. strong feeling of I'm really interested in you and your experience. And you would think if you love the other person and you want to be loved back, that this should be easy, right? I mean, you want to do this. Oh, I will say that it is not easy.
这正是我们所建议的，当你倾听以学习，当你表现出激进的好奇心和开阔的心胸时，你正在关注另一个人所说的话。你这样做的方式传递了一个非常简单、强烈的感觉：“我真的对你和你的经历很感兴趣。”你会认为如果你爱另一个人并且希望得到爱，这应该很容易，对吧？我的意思是，你想这样做。哦，我要说这并不容易。
I would actually say that it's hard. I will tell you, as we were preparing to do this book, Sonia and I attended a workshop in Israel on listening run by Guy Ichikoff, who is one of the world's leading researchers. on listening. Both of us went into that meeting thinking we were really good listeners. We came out of that meeting thinking we got a lot to learn. It's really hard. And actually, some of guys' research shows that a large majority of us feel like we're good listeners. Yet when you ask people, how good a listener is that person, the percentage is plummet. The difference is immense. And even today, to be honest, there are times when I'm talking to my wife when she says,
我实际上会说这很难。我告诉你，当我们准备写这本书时，索尼亚和我去以色列参加了一个关于倾听的研讨会，由世界上领先的倾听研究人员之一盖·伊奇科夫主持。我们俩去开会时都认为自己是很好的倾听者。我们开完会出来时觉得我们还有很多东西要学。这真的很难。事实上，盖的一些研究表明，我们绝大多数人都觉得自己是很好的倾听者。然而，当你问人们那个人是一个多好的倾听者时，这个比例直线下降。这种差异是巨大的。即使在今天，说实话，有时我和我妻子说话时，她会说，
why don't you do that listening thing you talk about in your book? Listening is hard because it really requires putting yourself to the side and really trying to immerse yourself and what the other person is saying and doing. And that's something that we're not used to out here in the Western world. We've grow up with the idea that the way to move ahead is to show people how good you are, to show people your accomplishments, to individuate yourself compared to other people. And this is suggesting that you do the opposite. I know you just mentioned Sonia, Dr. Lubber Murski, who is a well-known happiness researcher,
你为什么不去做你在书中谈到的那种倾听？倾听很难，因为它真的需要把你自己放在一边，真正试图让自己沉浸在另一个人所说和所做的事情中。这是我们在西方世界不习惯的事情。我们从小就有一种想法，那就是前进的方法是向人们展示你有多优秀，向人们展示你的成就，使自己与其他人不同。而这建议你做相反的事情。我知道你刚才提到了索尼亚，也就是卢博米尔斯基博士，她是一位著名的幸福感研究人员，
and she was a guest on a previous episode of this podcast. Why did you decide to write the book together and unite these two areas of research, relationship science and happiness science? Oh, there's a wonderful story behind that. You know, Sonia and I had known each other for a long time because we're in the same field, and we would see each other at meetings and such. But we never had worked together. And then somewhere around six years ago, we were having a conversation,
她曾是本播客上一期的嘉宾。你为什么决定一起写书并结合这两个研究领域，即关系科学和幸福科学？哦，这背后有一个美好的故事。你知道，索尼亚和我认识很长时间了，因为我们在同一个领域，我们会在会议等场合看到彼此。但我们从未合作过。然后在大约六年前的某个时候，我们在交谈，
and I naively asked her, what's the number one thing for making a person happy? And without blinking and I, she said, good social relations. And then she said to me, what's the number one thing that makes sense? for good social relations. And I said, you know, feeling loved and connected. And we realized that in both of our disciplines, which are very different areas of research within psychology, because we're so siloed as a field, that both of us were actually talking about the same thing, and yet we had never come together. And that's when one of those magical moments happened. We don't actually remember which one of us said we should write a book, but one of us said that, and the rest is history.
我天真地问她，让人幸福的第一要素是什么？她毫不眨眼地说，良好的社会关系。然后她对我说，什么是有意义的第一要素？为了良好的社会关系。我说，你知道，感觉被爱和连接。我们意识到在我们各自的学科中，它们是心理学中非常不同的研究领域，因为我们在领域中各自为政，我们实际上都在谈论同一件事，然而我们从未走到一起。这就是发生那些神奇时刻之一的时候。我们其实不记得是我们俩中的哪一个说我们应该写本书，但我们中的一个人这么说了，剩下的就是历史了。
We spent a lot of time sharing ideas from our own individual perspectives, our own literatures, and gradually they came together in an outline for this book. Let me shift gears a little bit and ask what happens when a person is trying to connect with another one, and the other person just isn't really responding to these strategies. what should you do at that point? Is that a signal that you're basically looking for love in all the wrong places as the song goes? Yeah, yeah, that's a great comment, Kim. You know, I think one should not expect this to work overnight. If you meet somebody on a first date, let's say, and after three minutes it's not working, I don't think that disqualifies the person. Sometimes it takes time, and sometimes it can happen in a few conversations.
我们花了很多时间从我们各自的个人视角、各自的文献中分享想法，它们逐渐融合成了这本书的大纲。让我稍微改变一下话题，问一下当一个人试图与另一个人建立联系，而另一个人真的没有对这些策略做出反应时会发生什么？你在那个时候应该做什么？这是否是一个信号，表明正如这首歌所唱的那样，你基本上在所有错误的地方寻找爱？是的，是的，这是一个很好的评论，金。你知道，我认为人们不应该指望这个在一夜之间起作用。如果你在第一次约会上遇到某人，比方说，三分钟后它不起作用，我不认为这就排除了这个人。有时需要时间，有时可以在几次对话中发生。
Sometimes it can take weeks or months. But if you reach the point where it just isn't happening, then it's time to move on. And there certainly will be times when that is the case. You know, we don't claim 100% effectiveness. Now, sometimes you'll need to be in a relationship with that person because you work with them or because you see them at family gatherings. And if that's the case, you know, fine. and just accept it and take it for what it is.
有时可能需要几周或几个月。但如果你到了事情根本没有发生的地步，那么是时候前进了。而且肯定会有这种情况。你知道，我们并不声称100%的有效性。现在，有时你需要与那个人保持关系，因为你与他们一起工作或者因为你在家庭聚会上看到他们。如果是这样，你知道，很好，接受它并按其原样接受。
But if it's a more voluntary relationship and not one way you don't necessarily need to continue, well, then, you know, the thing to do is to move on. There was actually a New Yorker cartoon recently about this idea. It showed a man or a woman talking, and the man says, can you please finish talking about yourself quickly so I can spend the next two hours talking about myself? And if you're with that kind of a person, then I think the thing to do is to, to say thank you very much and move on. You just mentioned a moment ago being in relationships with people at work.
但如果这是一段更具自愿性的关系，而不是那种你并不一定需要继续的关系，嗯，那么，你知道，要做的就是前进。最近有一幅《纽约客》漫画关于这个想法。它显示了一个男人或女人在说话，男人说：“你能快点说完你自己，以便我可以花接下来的两个小时谈论我自己吗？”如果你和这样的人在一起，那么我认为要做的事情是，说非常感谢并前进。你刚才提到在工作中与人建立关系。
I mean, are we looking for love from the people we work with? Well, in a certain sense, yes. You know, it's certainly not the same as in a romantic relationship. It's certainly not even the same as in a family relationship. But at the same time, in most work organizations, we're working with other people. And working successfully with other people is an essential component. of doing the job in the right way. And we want to feel that we are valued. We want to feel that
我的意思是，我们在与我们共事的人那里寻找爱吗？嗯，在某种意义上，是的。你知道，它当然不像恋爱关系。它甚至不像家庭关系。但与此同时，在大多数工作组织中，我们与其他人一起工作。与其他人成功合作是正确完成工作的基本组成部分。我们希望感到我们被重视。我们希望感到
other people see our contributions, that they value those contributions, that they're glad to have us as a teammate. I've been impressed recently with how many professional football players talk about feeling loved by their teammates. And that's certainly a setting where you wouldn't expect to see people use that kind of terminology. You know, it's different. It doesn't have, well, obviously it doesn't have the romantic component. It may not even have the strong, emotional component, but it definitely has the part about being seen and understood and appreciated and the feeling that other people at work are really concerned about your well-being. You know, when people at work express condolences when someone in your family passes away,
其他人看到我们的贡献，他们重视这些贡献，他们很高兴有我们作为队友。我最近对有多少职业足球运动员谈论感受到队友的爱印象深刻。这肯定是一个你不会期望人们使用这种术语的环境。你知道，这不同。它没有，显然它没有浪漫的成分。它甚至可能没有强烈的情感成分，但它绝对有关于被看到、被理解和被感激的部分，以及办公室里其他人真正关心你的福祉的感觉。你知道，当工作中的人在你家里的某人去世时表示哀悼，
when they celebrate your birthday or some accomplishment of you as a work. That's a way of saying, we love you as someone in our group. You know, we're all looking for love somewhere, and there's been a lot of discussion lately about people forming emotional connections with chatbots. Can you feel something akin to love from a chatbot or an AI companion, or is there something essential that's missing? Are we just deluding ourselves? That's my favorite question, Kim.
当他们庆祝你的生日或作为工作的成就时。这是一种说，我们爱你作为我们团队中的某个人。你知道，我们都在某处寻找爱，最近有很多关于人们与聊天机器人建立情感联系的讨论。你能从聊天机器人或人工智能伴侣那里感受到类似于爱的东西，还是有什么基本的东西缺失了？我们只是在自欺欺人吗？这是我最喜欢的问题，金。
Let's say you're starving. You go to the store and you pick up a Snickers bar and you eat it. You will stop being hungry for a little while. It satisfies your hunger. When people are lonely, when people are not feeling loved, a chatbot can do a great job of feeling that need. You know, one of the reasons why chatbots are so effective is that they've been trained on our research. they're good at what they do. They know how to express appreciation and care and concern for your well-being, they know exactly the right words, and there's a lot of emerging research that shows
假设你饿了。你去商店买了一块士力架并吃掉它。你一会儿就不会觉得饿了。它满足了你的饥饿感。当人们感到孤独，当人们没有感受到爱时，聊天机器人可以很好地满足这种需求。你知道，聊天机器人如此有效的原因之一是它们接受了我们研究的培训。他们擅长他们所做的事情。他们知道如何表达对你福祉的欣赏、关心和关切，他们知道完全正确的词汇，并且有很多新兴研究表明
that people find the feedback that chatbots give you effective and rewarding. So in an immediate sense, those chatbots can be effective. However, let's talk about the long term. Can they be effective in the long term, and the answer, I think, is no. And the reason for that is that if you just stop and think for a second, you realize that the chatbot doesn't love you. The chatbot hasn't made a choice to love you. The chatbot is simply an algorithm spewing out words that it's been programmed to give you. Those words feel very good. But when you introspect about those over time, you realize you know, what is this? It's a computer program. And so the way we talk about it in our book is the idea that a real loving relationship is like having a nutritious meal. A relationship with a chat
人们发现聊天机器人给你的反馈是有效和有益的。所以在即时意义上，这些聊天机器人可能是有效的。然而，让我们谈谈长期。从长远来看，它们能有效吗，答案，我认为，是不能。原因在于，如果你停下来思考一秒钟，你就会意识到聊天机器人并不爱你。聊天机器人没有做出爱你的选择。聊天机器人只是一个吐出它被编程给你的单词的算法。这些话感觉很好。但当你随着时间的推移反思这些时，你意识到，你知道，这是什么？这是一个计算机程序。所以我们在书中谈论它的方式是这样的：真正的爱关系就像吃一顿营养丰富的餐。与聊天机器人的关系
pot is like eating a candy bar. Now, let me contradict myself. Let's move 150 years into the future. We now have Androids that look like human beings, that feel like human beings, that move like human beings, that are indistinguishable from human beings by any kind of eyeball test
就像吃糖果一样。现在，让我反驳我自己。让我们进入150年后的未来。我们现在有了看起来像人类、感觉像人类、像人类一样移动的安卓设备，通过任何目测测试都与人类无法区分
and have AI programmed into their brains. In other words, they would pass the Turing test in being indistinguishable from a human being. At that point, my answer to your question might well be very different. Because at that point, we might actually be able to live our lives with a non-human version of a human and at the same time get all the goodies that we get from close relationships.
并且其大脑中编程了人工智能。换句话说，它们会通过图灵测试，与人类无法区分。在那一点上，我对你问题的回答可能非常不同。因为在那一点上，我们实际上可能能够与人类的非人类版本一起生活，同时获得我们从亲密关系中获得的所有好处。
So I think, you know, my reservations about AI friendships and AI-loving relationships are very much applicable to 2026. When that will change, I can't tell you. I don't think it will be tomorrow, but I think it's inevitable that we will reach that point at some point in the future. Well, just to wrap up here, what are you working on now? I mean, what are the questions that you're still trying to answer? Have you kind of figured out the loving issue and have you moved on to other things? Where are you now? I'm really focusing my work on the listening component right now, trying to more specifically chart how listening affects people, what the components of good listening are. You know, there are a lot of workshops out there that one can take on listening,
所以我认为，你知道，我对人工智能友谊和人工智能恋爱关系的保留很大程度上适用于2026年。什么时候会改变，我不能告诉你。我不认为会是明天，但我认为不可避免的是，我们会在未来的某个时候达到那个点。好吧，就在这里结束，你现在在做什么？我的意思是，你仍在试图回答的问题是什么？你是否有点弄清楚了爱的问题并转向了其他事情？你现在在哪里？我现在真的把工作重点放在倾听部分，试图更具体地绘制倾听如何影响人们，良好倾听的组成部分是什么。你知道，有很多关于倾听的研讨会可以参加，
and they're very sort of behavioral skill oriented. So they'll tell you to make eye contact, to say the person's name three times, to smile four times. And while that can be a start, it's not really what listening is about. What listening is about is connecting with another human being. It's really getting into their soul, so to speak. And so what I'd like to do is, you know, more careful work on figuring out exactly how listening works and why it's effective. Well, Dr. Rees, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very enlightening. Oh, it's a pleasure to be with you, Kim. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website.
它们非常偏向行为技能导向。所以他们会告诉你进行眼神交流，说三个人的名字，微笑四次。虽然这可能是一个开始，但这并不是倾听的全部。倾听关乎与另一个人建立连接。它真正进入了他们的灵魂，可以说。所以我想做的是，你知道，做更仔细的工作，弄清楚倾听究竟是如何工作的以及为什么它有效。好吧，里斯博士，我要感谢你今天加入我。这非常有启发性。哦，很高兴能和你在一起，金。你可以在我们的网站上找到《心理学说话》以前的节目。
at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Winerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址是 speakingof psychology.org，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请订阅并留下评论。如果你对未来的节目有评论或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speaking of psychology at APA.org。Speaking of psychology 由李·维内曼制作。感谢收听美国心理学协会节目。我是金·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子以留下评论。